In Hebrew you say, "meharagelayim"
like by your feet.
And you have to experience it yourself.
You have to push yourself
to your limits and understand that, like,
there's more that you can do.
You don't have to succumb
to the stress, pressure or whatever
is in front of you at the moment.
Nuri Golan,
thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you today?
I'm good.
How are you?
I'm doing great.
I'm very jealous of you.
You get to meet Shuly and Gil
on an ongoing basis.
And I miss them so much
ever since I came back to Israel
for the covid times.
So, please send them
my love and my regards.
But enough about them.
Nuri, such a fascinating journey
that you've taken.
And perhaps one of the most
fascinating pieces of it
is right in the beginning
as a captain in the Israeli Navy Seals,
turning into running R&D
for that same unit.
And then the boring stuff,
selling a company
and creating another startup,
sitting on advisory boards.
But that's the boring stuff.
Let's go back to the beginning.
Nuri, how do you get
to be a combat officer in the Navy Seals?
Lots of reasons for wanting to do that,
but most importantly, you know,
I grew up in a very zionist family.
A lot of my uncles and my dad
all served in the Israeli military.
So, when I was a teenager,
I started to think about it
and then I actually was within Israel
during the second Lebanon war in 2006.
And it was a really
interesting experience being there.
I think I was 19 at the time.
And everyone your age
is kind of out at war.
And so, being there
and having a good time in Tel Aviv,
but not seeing anybody your age
really has an impact on you.
And someone who always
kind of thought about wanting to serve
and do something
a little bit bigger than me,
that was the kind of the straw
that broke the camel's back
and I decided I wanted
to join the Israeli military.
So, I finished my degree.
So, I was studying
at George Washington University
at the time, aerospace engineering.
So, I spent another two years
completing my degree.
And then in 2008,
I got on a plane with my cousin
and the two of us made Aliyah
and joined.
And then I thought
I was only going to go for two years
and then come back to the US.
And you ended up at nine.
Yeah. I got accepted
to the Navy SEAL entry exam.
And on my way there somebody told me,
"Do you know that this is
at least five years service."
And I said,
"I didn't know that, but okay."
And once I passed and they admitted me
and invited me to start training,
I just couldn't give up the opportunity.
Nuri, I have to say that, you know,
I'm sure that
a lot of my friends in Israel
who are going to be listening to this
are already getting frustrated
because, you know,
it's known how insanely difficult it is
to get accepted to the Navy SEALs.
You know, the gibush is one of the most
notorious difficult experiences
that any young 18 or 17 year-olds
can go through
and getting accepted there is remarkable.
And I'm sure that it's quite a big shock
also coming from university,
studying aerospace engineering
and landing all of a sudden
in this five, six year program
where you're literally,
you know, drinking seawater
and eating sand.
Talk to me a little bit about
this experience of going
from George Washington University
straight into the Navy SEALs.
Well, it's definitely a shock.
There were many moments
where I stood there.
I think one of the,
during the five day entry exam,
the gibush,
at one point, it was like
there was a lightning storm out
and they were
making us running out of the water.
And I was holding this giant,
like metal anchor.
And they told me
to go throw it in the water
so we could go
like, run around it in circles.
And I'm like looking up at the sky,
thinking I'm about to get hit
by lightning carrying this giant thing.
And I'm like, what the hell
am I doing here?
How did I get here?
But, you know, at the time, again,
I was 21 at the time
I was locked in, focused.
This is what I wanted to do.
And so, you know,
that kind of takes over
any of the critical thinking parts
of your brain
and you just kind of run with it.
It's definitely a challenge
for me at least.
Like some of the most challenging parts
weren't necessarily the physical pieces
but dealing with, you know,
having officers and commanders
who were younger than me.
Who didn't really have a ton
of life experience, you know,
it was really funny.
Like, I had a degree, again,
I wasn't exactly like the most mature
and sophisticated person in the world,
but I had an engineering degree
and people are looking at me
like I'm only going to start my college
in like five or six years
after I finished the US military,
go travel for two years,
take a year off.
So, that for me,
was one of the most difficult parts.
So, just for context,
I want to move forward on your journey
just so we can get the context
as to the type of person you are.
But then I really want to circle back
and go back
to these extraordinary lessons
that one can learn
in the combat unit.
Because the truth be told,
most of Israelis in the tech scene,
especially those
that are in Silicon Valley,
they're not coming
from these elite combat unit.
So, a lot of them are coming from,
you know, 8200, 81,
all those elite technological units.
And so, I'm extremely excited
to hear your perspective
on the different leadership lessons.
But walk me through some
of the different experiences you've had,
like with EXO that was acquired by Lear,
and then sitting on advisory boards
in your most recent startup.
Are you asking
about those experiences specifically, or?
Yeah.
Give me the rundown of what happened
since you left,
just so we can get the context.
So, I finished my service.
And I always, like startup world
and entrepreneurship
was something that was always
interesting to me.
And I ended up doing my MBA
at the Technion which had a startup
in innovation program, specifically.
Casual.
And so, that kind of is
where everything started.
They basically tell you, like,
you should start a company
and use this as an incubator for,
you know, to build your idea.
And so, I was lucky enough
to meet a couple of partners.
One of which was the guy
who led the GPS squadron
in the US Air Force.
So, he had some ideas
about how to improve the accuracy of GPS.
Obviously, that was
like, okay, this can be a very big deal.
And so, we started a company around it.
And yeah, like the
lessons in the training
that you get in the military,
in my opinion,
are some of the best
that an entrepreneur can get.
Like, you're right,
when I go around in Silicon Valley,
pitching a VC, they ask me,
"Were you in 8200? Were you in 81?"
you know,
they already know those buzzwords.
And I was like,
"Oh no, I was in 13."
They were like, "What is that?"
I'm like, the opposite end of the spectrum.
But I think that, you know,
like the training that you do
you're used to working under
serious time constraints,
never knowing what the next minute
is going to be,
let alone the next week or month.
You know, intense conditions,
everything is up and down
and you have to learn to keep yourself
kind of really levelheaded.
And so, I think, like
the best entrepreneur lessons
I ever learned were in the training
that I got in the military.
And I think that helped me,
you know, through EXO where
we are trying to sell deep tech company
or the technology product to a lot of,
to like the automotive industry,
which was at the time, you know,
it's still a very difficult industry
to sell into especially for startups.
You have a lot of highs and lows
and being able to manage that
is one of the most critical parts
of running an early stage startup.
Right.
So, you've done that,
you've done it once,
you're doing it again now, at Sosivio.
What is Sosivio?
So, Sosivio is a autonomous cloud
native platform.
So, it helps you manage your,
it's like a next generation
of observability tool
for managing your online
and cloud native services.
And so we help any company of any size,
generally some of the larger companies
that are moving
into the cloud more and more
so, keep their applications running
and keeping their environments optimized.
So, it sounds like
it's definitely sounds like something
that's necessary to do.
But, what is the problem?
Because, you know,
from most people's perspective,
we look at all the big tech companies
that we have today,
obviously, they're running in the cloud
and obviously every startup
is starting out in the cloud.
I think people will quickly forget
that the majority of the world
is not in the cloud.
I don't know exactly what percentage,
maybe you can enlighten me,
but I still believe that
a lot of the big core enterprises
that we've seen, that we've rolled in
from the 20th century
have yet to make that transition.
Am I right?
Well, yeah.
I mean, cloud is just also
one of those terms that
you don't know exactly what you mean.
Like cloud, a lot of people today,
they think that means
you're running on AWS
or Google or Azure.
But really like anything that
where you're running an application,
not on your own computer
is cloud technically.
Right?
Like you're running
something somewhere else.
And to do that,
you have to use
a ton of different software
and services and tools
to help keep it running smoothly.
And so, observability
is one piece of that world
which is just helping keep your services
up and running.
Like everyone's had the experience where
they are using an application,
it could be a banking app on your phone
and it just crashes on you.
Like, why did that happen,
why does it happen only
once out of 100 times.
Well, there could be a number
of circumstances
in how the environment is operating,
where in that one moment
when enough people are using it,
the system crashes.
And so, what we do is we are able
to figure out much earlier
before those failures materialize,
like what's going on
and whether or not
something's going to happen.
So, we predicted ahead of time
and help you make sure it doesn't affect
your customers experience.
Wow. And where are you at
with that journey right now?
So, I know that
your a part of Upwest Labs,
a phenomenal, phenomenal group.
But what's been the journey like
for Sosivio?
Yeah, I mean, the company was started
earlier this year.
Me and one of my co-founders from EXO,
and then Adam, Avi, and Liran
are the other co-founders, started it up.
We raised a little bit of money.
We're raising money again right now,
which is always a fun process
and starting to build it out.
We have a core product
that's being released.
And we're working
with a number of partners already.
So, it's very exciting time.
And what's been the most
biggest learning experience
or the learning curve
that you had to adapt to
as you are transitioning?
Because on one,
it is very different
from everything else you've done, right?
I understand coming
from a military background
when we still have to talk
about the leadership experience
that you have gained there,
but I understand the technical background
you've gained there.
The GPS deep technology
military application
makes a lot of sense.
And now you're moving on
to helping big enterprises
make a transition towards
the cloud world
with predictive analysis
on when things might go wrong.
It doesn't connect in my mind.
Help me work this out.
I mean,
you don't always have to be
the industry expert yourself
to run a successful business or startup.
I think that, you know,
there's a lot of other factors
you can talk about,
like leadership, right?
Like having someone
who can just steer the ship
in the right way,
know how to build the company
and bring in the right people
and the right experience,
the right talent.
That's critically important.
And so, this is a brand new space for me,
which is a challenge,
and it's actually a challenge
that I embrace it.
You know, I was excited about
trying something new
and not just staying in the same field
for the rest of my life.
For me, like what I want to do
is I want to continuously build companies
and learn of it.
But one of the cool things
about doing this is that
you get to learn a whole new space
and you get to learn
a whole new world of technology,
a whole new world of people.
And that to me is exciting.
So, it's not that there's
a direct connection between GPS
and cloud services,
it's more that the recipe for building
a good startup is pretty much the same
no matter what industry you're in.
And it sounds to me like the key ingredient
all the way from studying aerospace
in George Washington to go
into the Navy SEALs
to running R&D in the Navy SEALs
to selling a GPS company
to now doing this as curiosity.
I mean, it sounds like
you're just passionate
about whatever you're doing.
You are embracing that challenge.
You mentioned before
when you were just doing that gibush,
that you're sort of trained your mind
to stop that critical thinking
and to embrace the challenge
and to run headfirst.
And it sounds like
there's a lot of parallelism
to what you experienced
going into perhaps
one of the most difficult
units of the IDF
and one of the most prestigious units
to running a startup.
Am I right?
Yeah. I mean, there's
I'm a pretty analytical person.
I like to sit down
and think through problems.
But there comes a time where
you need to just run through a wall.
And I think that's like
one of the things that going through
you know,
the Israeli Navy SEALs really helps you
like, you can think about
every aspect of a problem
and you can have a perfect strategy.
Occasionally you're just going to come up
against an obstacle
and you need to get through it
in whatever way possible.
And I think that's a piece that
you know, it's not something
you can teach someone or tell someone.
They can only learn it on their own.
Like in Hebrew you say, "meharagelayim",
like by your feet.
You have to experience it yourself.
You have to push yourself to your limits
and understand that, like
there's more that you can do,.
You don't have to succumb to the stress,
pressure or whatever's in front of you
at the moment.
Right. That makes a lot of sense.
I'm thinking back
to some experiences I had.
I came from 8200.
I wish I came from,
like an experience like the Navy SEALs.
Unfortunately, I probably couldn't get in
even if I applied.
But I remember that
a lot of the times we had these struggles
and we had to develop these technologies
and we just didn't have the funds
to do them.
And we said, okay, well,
we need this server,
we need this technology
and we need this type of person.
And I would go to my commander
and he would say, okay, no, no,
and unfortunately no.
So, good luck.
You still have a week to get it done.
Right?
So, at that point, you're saying,
okay, there's a wall
and you just have to break it.
What's leadership like
in the Navy SEALs?
What is it like being a combat leader?
Well, you know, by the way,
being a combat leader
and being like a startup leader
are two very different things.
And I would actually argue that
that being a startup leader
or in the business world
can actually be more difficult
in a lot of ways.
Being a combat leader, you know,
like in the military,
you have a rank, you have authority,
like there is some things that are given
from the beginning that make it
a little bit easier.
Where in the business world,
especially in the Israeli business world,
you have to earn your place
because people will challenge you
all the time.
And so, you know,
at the end of the day,
like in the military, yes,
you'll have the rank
and you'll have the position,
but you need to own up to it.
Like you need to protect your people,
you need to be, you know,
lead by example,
if I had to boil it all down
to like one point,
it would be lead by example.
Like, if you
preach to people certain things,
you don't hold yourself
to the same standards,
you'll be toast in no time
because the people won't respect you.
So, for me, that was like
the guiding light always was.
Whatever I asked my teams to do
or my people to do,
I better make sure
that I hold myself
to that exact same standard.
And if you do,
there's really never going to be
complaints from the people below you.
Because if you're doing it,
then why shouldn't they.
Right?
If you're the higher rank,
if you're the person
who should have the better benefits,
better things, like
they have no reason to complain.
Right. And I think
one of the very special things
also about these different amazing units
in the IDF is that
a lot of the times
the commanders are the ones
who are doing the heavy lifting early on.
And especially, I know in my unit
and I'm sure also in the Navy SEALs
that the people that are promoted,
that are commanding
and are leading the teams
are people that were, perhaps,
the best soldiers and the best
that both mentally and physically
and emotionally.
So, I'm definitely sure of that.
What about the hand tackling?
It's different type of challenge?
You know, when you take a team
that is tired,
that is beaten down
and now you have to take that metal bar
and run into the sea and throw it.
It's a very different task
than guiding somebody to work late,
to deploy a new version or fix a bug.
It must be very different.
Yeah. I mean, of course.
Look, one of the good,
we talk about the differences
between business leadership
and combat leadership,
in the military unit,
one of the advantages is that everybody
has a very clear common mission.
Which is another
very important aspect of leadership.
It's like a business unit.
The business all the time about
what's the business's
mission statement
and what are you about.
And that is an attempt to solidify
a group around a common cause.
In the military,
you have that built in.
It's like, okay,
we all know what we're here for.
Especially in Israel, right?
We're here to make sure
that the country survives till next year.
So, you know,
it's about making everybody understand
that that's what they're there for.
The risk and the circumstances
are obviously a lot more significant
in a combat role.
And so, you know,
that helps in some ways too,
because you become a lot closer
to the people you're around.
Like the brotherhood that you build
in the fraternity of the teams
that you work with.
You know, even to this day, like,
I obviously have a lot of good friends
who weren't in the military,
but friends who did serve,
especially friends who served,
you know, on the front line,
it doesn't matter
if they were special forces or not.
There's a different kind
of connection there.
Again, that's no disrespect
to anyone who didn't serve
in those roles but,
there's something there
that you just can't recreate
in the outside world.
And even in the business world,
it's very difficult to do that.
100%.
My father was a pilot.
I guess maybe 40 years ago
in the Air Force.
And there's not a week goes by
where he doesn't mention
an amazing friend
that he had in the course, as if,
as if they did
a program together last week.
And you can feel the bond
that people are creating
this lifelong partnership
which it's just phenomenal.
You had a short stint in venture capital.
Something that
not a lot of entrepreneurs get.
And you are as young as you are,
so, how was that?
Was it fun?
Was it enlightening?
Did you benefit from that towards
the next startup?
Yeah, absolutely.
It was, first of all, I think,
as most of the venture capitalists
usually come from
an entrepreneurial role of some kind.
I think it's incredibly important
to have been on the other side,
to see what the startup is like.
You look at things a lot differently
on that side than
when you're on the entrepreneur side.
You really like,
you can see when a startup is maybe,
you know,
extending the truth a little bit
or you know, things pop out at you
that maybe they didn't before.
I know I'm sure that these guys
are having this problem
and just by the way
that they're speaking about it.
So, it's invaluable experience.
And then now back
on the entrepreneur side,
it's also very, very valuable
because now,
you know, when you go to pitch a VC
you know what they're looking for,
you know how busy they are,
you know how like
sometimes their attention spans
can just be completely
too short to really listen to you.
So, you know, kind of where
the heart is in and where to focus
and it's certainly like incredible.
I recommend that both sides
do both roles.
I think it will just be more productive
for everyone.
When I was doing that role at Lear,
I felt from the entrepreneurs as well
that they appreciated it as well,
like having, especially
in corporate venture capital.
Because that's typically
where you don't get, like, entrepreneurs,
in a VC, again, like I was saying,
usually they have some
entrepreneurial experience.
In a corporate venture capital world,
not a lot of them have their own
entrepreneurial experience.
Because they're coming in from
internally within the organization.
Yes.
I was kind of an out and I didn't stay.
I was only a leader
for two and a half years.
But a lot of entrepreneurs who acquired
either move, you know,
they stay in the operations role
of running that business
or eventually they phase out.
I grew the team within Lears of EXO
and then eventually joined
and helped launch
the innovation organization
and took over the venture capital part.
But that was unique
or definitely not the norm,
I would say.
Wow.
Nuri, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
Really, really wonderful.
Before we go, I have to ask you
for the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
I'm particularly curious
to hear what you have to say
because of your extraordinary experience.
I would say competitive is number one.
Most people who,
do have to explain them
or just give you the words?
If you can explain in a short sentences,
I would love that.
Most people who know me
know that I'm extremely competitive
about everything.
And I joke including about
who's more competitive, so.
We're going to save this competition
for the next episode
because we have a competition
going on here.
Yeah.
Disciplined, I would say number two.
Where again, like,
especially in entrepreneurship
and obviously in the military,
like being disciplined to yourself
not just the outside world,
like again, holding yourself to standards.
Even when you tell people a certain thing
like, Hey, you got to wake up
at this time,
you got to do this, this and this,
a lot of times people aren't going
to be there to see you or do it.
And it's, you know,
still important to hold yourself
to the same standards
because, it's not about
actually doing those things.
It's about the mentality of like,
here's what we're going to do to it.
And then three, I would say dedicated.
Something else that drives me a lot,
is when I get into something,
I'm in it fully.
So, that's I guess number three.
Nuri, I knew you wouldn't disappoint
those three words,
Nuri, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
By the way, I think
that those three words
didn't come up in any
of the other 250 episodes.
Because this was a very special episode,
it's one that's very dear to my heart
because as I traverse along my journey,
especially in Palo Alto,
sometimes it's not easy to explain
the experience of being
in an organization like the IDF.
And it's also a different,
I think, from a lot of other
military experiences as well.
I have friends who served
in different militaries.
This innovation through necessity,
this discipline, this being,
you know, I remember when I enlisted
and the first week that I enlisted,
I came as 19 straight from Palo Alto.
I was doing a year there
with Professor Dan Ariely.
I had a 19 year old girl
who was screaming at me for forgetting
to tie my shoes a certain way.
And I remember that moment
that it just dawned on me that, okay,
this is a new reality
and we're going to do some great things.
And it was a fantastic experience.
Nuri, Thank you very much.
It was a pleasure.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Good luck.